tu le connaissais n'est-ce pas alors tu as eu
ce petit sentiment
mais tu l'as écarté
tu aurais dû écouter ce
petit sentiment
tout comme je t'écoute maintenant tu
peux me parler
je suis tout un ami tu as
vous n'êtes pas exactement un favori du département
, la chose a probablement beaucoup changé depuis qu'il est
parti,
vous devez toujours l'attraper, oui,
pas beaucoup d'échanges, alors
je peux vous assurer que nous adoptons une
approche 24 heures sur 24, 7 jours sur 7, pour ces
cas
.  requin s'il s'arrête il meurt il
aime conduire a probablement une voiture décente
peut-être deux
kilométrage élevé vous devez vraiment aimer ma voiture
je fais comment est l'espace du coffre
quelque chose que j'ai appris à savoir comment va le gars
avec le meilleur taux de dédouanement du
département travaille 15 ans  sans
promotion
peut-être que je ne suis pas allé à la bonne église
quand je regarde dans tes yeux ce que je vois
ce n'est pas bon
il connaissait tous les détails mais il n'était pas à
moins de 10 miles du meurtre
pourquoi haïr ça pourquoi c'est ça
[  Musique]
comment est l'espace du coffre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que faire  tu veux je veux clouer le
bâtard pour
toutes les filles qu'il a tuées
[Musique]
je veux clouer le panier aussi la
différence est que
je fais ça pour moi
ce sont les
petites choses
qui t'attrapent